the Adam Carolla Show out of five days a
week and get it on podcast one just like
this podcast as well there's a lot of
podcasts at the Grove of Anaheim coming
up on Friday November 30th with Rob
Riggle being the guest to the host of
the Adam Carolla Show and so much more
good to see you ace man how are you sir
I'm better now
because you're good people it's good if
you were being chased by a bear but if
you just got out of your air-conditioned
Jag and sat in an air-conditioned studio
probably doesn't apply but you're here
right and you are here as well and you
rolled up into the Rich Eisen show with
some signage on the side of your car we
had help but notice I forgot about this
piano professional piano tuning yeah for
the Hollywood stars should we read off
the phone number go ahead eight eight
eight six three four seventeen forty
four and there's a nice logo of some
keys with a Yelp and everything yeah
have you opened a new business huh no I
did okay this is a convoluted first
world problem but uh-huh I was walking
my dog through my neighborhood and you
know when you walk around up head on a
swivel like Bill Bergey dropping back
into a hook zone nice and I noticed
things like and so I see people put the
Christmas decorations out early and
often and the Halloween decorations and
I go that's the winner family and then
we're the family with nothing like we
can't even get our exterior lights on
the timer and blah blah blah
I passed the house it had a an SUV
parked in front of it said professional
piano tuning and I thought whoever lives
in that house is a winner because they
must have a Steinway or some grand piano
and that this guy they're smarter they
speak languages they're educated they're
probably sitting around like Dudley
Moore in the 80s at a cocktail party you
know and whatever's going on and we're
just sitting in our house eating Taco
Bell and arguing with each other over
fortnight and I want whatever's going
they seem smart yeah now I'm not buying
a piano and I'm not gonna learn to play
the piano and my kids don't play the
piano nobody speaks any languages or
plays any instruments but the
neighborhood doesn't have to know that
so I got it I have a nanny she has a
rav4 but it's it's good enough sure and
I got a sign made I said I'm gonna put
this on your car and when it's parked in
front of my house people think there's
something serious going on inside that
house the neighbors will think this guy
must be a winner because he's always
getting his piano tuned and my daughter
who's 12 and thinks she's 37 refused to
drive in the car with the piano tuning
because she want to be dropped off in
front of her school with her nanny yeah
thinking that there picked up at school
with the piano tuning sign on there so
she's boycotted the car until the sign
was removed now I have a magnetic sign
I paid 150 bucks well it's perfectly
good I'm not gonna throw it away I can't
force it on the nanny's car cuz my
daughter won't drive in a car so I have
to put it on my car that's an elaborate
scheme Adam but everyone who sees me
thinks I'm a winner because they go look
at that guy's driving a nice car he
tunes pianists like he must know
something or you could just be that
individual for the Hollywood stars logo
on it yeah I want it to seem realistic I
don't want it to seem like a goof the
phone number is my podcast phone number
okay it does go something so it's it's
your dialling number for your show voted
best piano tuner on Yelp like 10 years
that's gilding the lily you know and I'm
already it's already a little suspicious
that the piano tuners constantly parked
in front of your house you know but one
year could have been a fluke so that
your neighbors say anything to you
there's a lot of like quiet knowing nod
I mean like I feel like there's a kind
of respect yeah that is an unspoken but
it's understood hmm I'm I'm gonna try
this myself
I don't know well it's tough it is
strong yeah no I don't want to be a
copycat
yeah what other business do you think
could be used to connote some form of as
you say multilingual yeah you know
enlightened intelligent focused yeah
happy family would reside inside the
house if you see that on the side of
your car yeah I know it's tough cause
like there's life coach and
chiropractors dancing the ballroom
dancing is good strong it does skew a
little old true okay like a Latin
professor now that his hip surgery is
you know in in the rear view there he
can get back to his love of fall
Abraham's work right right yeah but it's
that bad we're just spitballing here
spitballing Adam Carolla here on the
Rich Eisen show by the way now that I'm
parked in front of the studio everyone's
good people outside the building think
wow something going on in there the Rich
Eisen show got a new sorry Yamaha cuz I
saw on your sign it's you specialize
that is an elaborate scheme well oh well
done thank you I forgot it was on my car
that's the thing when you put stuff on
your car you you forget about it are you
up I mean the Rams obviously that's your
team you know now they lost yesterday
yeah did you take the game in did you I
did okay I mean it was nice to see him
come back it was you know you always I'm
a big Rams fan of course but Drew Brees
is so easy to root for because he's such
a class act and he's getting better with
a
age and it was really that third and
seven where he just took it to the house
like probably most other quarterbacks
would have tried just to move the chains
at that point in the game but he put it
he went up top they took it to the house
pulled the cell phone out would you
think of that I it's a little I gotta
tell you if I can't bring half a bottle
of water through airport security you
shouldn't be able to hide stuff under
the goalposts that you get during the
game you know what I mean like to me
it's a security issue I got a half
bottle of water and I'm trying to make
it through the security thing and the
guy showing you drink it or dump it and
then I'm weird cuz I don't like the way
stuff by the way oh
this idea yeah I hate wasting good clean
water I feel like that's a commodity the
rest of the world doesn't have access to
it and then we're just dumping it in
this big trash can or we do what I
always do which is I end up just
chugging it because I don't want to
throw away the water I'm convinced you
know like in the past I had like coal
miners along there's gonna be frequent
travelers liver we're like I get a
floating liver like it's a syndrome from
chugging too much bottled water because
you just pay $12 for this bottle of
water at the kiosk and now you're like
I'm not gonna throw away $8 worth of
water so I finished a marathon so this
is what you think of when Michael Thomas
pulls a cell phone from underneath ago
no I'm digressing but what they should
have is a ficus tree there there should
be a potted plant and then we could all
feel like we're doing our part right it
also cleans the air such people in the
better mood and all that kind of stuff
but I don't like the notion of stashing
things on the field in advance
there was a Bruce Willis movie called
like The Last Boy Scout or something
where somebody hid like a gun on the
50-yard line and the guy was riding a
horse shooting people in the Coliseum
and all I'm saying is is if I can't get
through the airport with the half a
bottle Avion you know you shouldn't be
able to stash stuff on the field well I
assume you know it's just a phone I
guess you
you wouldn't set anything off of it's
just like I have to put the phone
through in the bin and through the x-ray
machine and that's all that's all I'm
saying it wasn't that it well you know
what you and I are lockstep on most
things Adam Carolla and certainly in the
sports world whether it's the replay
[ __ ] that you I believe came up with on
your first appearance here on the show
or when I was on your show where there's
a sort of pulp fiction like [ __ ] that's
hidden beneath the stadium that's
brought out to make rulings whether a
call should stand or not or the atom
poll that you came out with it there
should be a poll in between the two
uprights that if you hit it directly
it's worth more points than just a
regular field goal here lockstep with
you I do have to take issue is something
you tweeted out during the World Series
here and I know this might be
particularly provincial here in Los
Angeles the Dodger dog you say is the
worst hot dog they were on planet Earth
or in the countries what you said yeah I
have to disagree with you I don't know
what it is it it doesn't look good I'll
tell you that the the eye test you see
it it's wrong it's crumpled up it looks
terrible but I don't know what there's
something in it it's it's kind of like
manna from heaven
Adam well you know I I think there's a
situation and by the way who you gonna
believe America the guy with the
football helmet that came with ice cream
in it or the guy's a professional piano
tuner specializes in Yamaha and burgundy
our fur comes with ice cream in it or
this guy who tunes pianos on a
professional level who the stars by the
way check the L premieres running two
years running I say this about the
Dodger dog I say I make the same
argument as people do that's with reggae
music I tell them I don't like reggae
music and then they go oh come on you're
on the beach
you got a pina colada in your hand your
Tootsie's are in the Caribbean you got a
beautiful local giving you a back rub
I got no no that you can't compare it
you have to be stuck in traffic sitting
on the 105 with a van in front of you
and
and do you enjoy Dodger dog great
there's seventh-inning your guys are up
you're the organist is playing you got a
cold one in your right hand and the
Dodger dog and the left hand fine it's
enjoyable but I say it's enjoyable
because of the environment I'm saying if
you just took a Dodger dog and brought
it to your home and someone said get in
your underwear put some black socks on
and eat it standing up you'd be
miserable you'd be miserable and by the
way if you ever served a Dodger dog in
Chicago they would burn the stadium
little brown that's that's I understand
there's no casing it's just it's a it's
a tube of meat that's what I was about
to say I mean on a food food stuff level
is that where you have the issue
I like this snap I like the casing it's
a it's it's it's a battle the you know
the the grilled dog versus the sort of
poached boiled dog but I me the
Chicagoan dog with the casing and the
snap and the little Russia juice and the
sort of steam the steam bun that's the
best dog for me see now that's what I
wanted to bring it up to you because you
know your your first theory all piano
tuning aside just stripping it all down
any food that served at a stadium if you
bring it into your house you wouldn't
want to eat standing up and your
underwear and black socks unless you
have geezers
is there a food somewhere that you'd say
that could actually I want of the
stadium you know would enjoy the
carnation malted ice cream that they
give you the wooden paddle that always
snaps in half the bottom of it the
basically give they take those things
and they dip them in liquid nitrogen and
they give you I can do two scoops of ice
cream in well under ten minutes but it
takes an hour and 45 minutes to just get
the top layer of that thing off because
it's flash-frozen
and you have an ore that's made of balsa
wood to temp to eat it
I would enjoy eating that in my kitchen
for the sheer
novelty of it like I've never seen that
thing outside of a stadium has anyone
ever seen that carnation frozen weird
ice cream block day that's our side of a
stadium anniversary I've never seen it
either
I've never eaten fiesta mix on the
ground
I've only been 30,000 feet in the air on
a miserable Southwest flight look I've
known never been sitting in my kitchen
when honey where's the Fiesta miss Thea
is that what they call it I'm in it yeah
why is it a fiesta I mean there's a
party in your mouth right because
there's just there's a whole crop of
things that no one would ever eat on the
ground but you'll eat them 30,000 feet
in the air because your captive well
that's and that's why and thus bring you
in all full circles while you think a
Dodger dog might be tasty seventh-inning
somewhere within the confines of Dodger
Stadium but outside not at all I think
if you're having a 4th of July party and
you served up Dodger dogs versus a good
kosher dog people would be miserable ok
we play a game here called start bench
cut Adam cruel it's kind of like you
know blank marry kill we have to choose
to start one item mm-hmm
bench one and cut another all right
we've come up with some constructs for
you here ok here on the Rich Eisen show
here ok so you have to start one bench
one cut one with Adam Carolla most
disgusting things about air travel dogs
at airports and airplanes conditions of
bathroom on airplanes shoes off on
airplanes you have to start one cut one
bench one mmm the cut one would be the
dog and and I got a policy because now
everywhere I go every Airport I travel
all over the place yes and now there's
dogs all over the place and their dogs
are going to the bathroom and the
terminals and this sent the other we
need to rein it in and I have a great
way to do that which is everyone has
just got these falsified papers from
their doctor Vinny boombots on the
Internet and they wrote him a note and
they sent him a thing and they've got a
card now they can travel with their dog
we go to LAX we find dogs we check the
legitimacy of this paperwork if it's not
legitimate we take the dog away and we
use it like we use the air cannon when
we fire the dead chickens into the
impellers of the jet engines to test the
metallurgy of the impellers on the jet
engines we'd only have to do it once
before people stop bringing their fake
service dogs to LAX we just take the one
dog we load it into the air cannon we
rolls-royce 777 inch and spooled up just
boom right into it fluffy is eviscerated
and we immediately end this problem so
so know you're with me on this operating
on a different level the dog has to go
benched is I'm sorry cut dog is cut yeah
benched is the people with the feet off
okay the shoes off and the feet
everywhere they're on the tables they're
their birds they're everywhere and it's
all of society okay you go to the
Starbucks the guy you know what we did
we made it okay to wear flip-flops
outside and the second we made it okay
to wear flip-flops outside we're one
move away from this and this that's what
happened you understand if I if I was
wearing flip-flops right now have both
bare feet on your desk you why shouldn't
you kick off flip-flops right we made it
okay to fly in flip-flops oh we made it
okay to go to movies bar mitzvahs
weddings I see people wearing flip-flops
the funerals it's it's it's okay maybe a
little hyperbole the point is this the
flip flop ruin it and I will start the
bathroom not not that I want to but I
know that but I will okay next one for
fur
you'd least like to celebrate
Valentine's Day Father's Day birthdays
it's a slippery slope here first off can
I say can we do this that's we
Valentine's and anniversaries now just
turned in to prove prove you still love
me
a day right like when did this become
our territory couldn't we split this one
up why do I have to do something for the
anniversary so my wife thinks I still
love her and Valentine's wouldn't it be
fair to just 1 M 1 or combine the two
why they're both on our docket like
shouldn't we shouldn't we divide and
conquer here like ladies you'll be in
charge of the anniversary no beer and
then send them the birthday this is
unfair and I'll tell you why it's unfair
I don't care about my birthday I want
birthday replaced with achievement day
like I know everyone was born all the
worst people in the world were born
how about achievement day how about the
day I was certified to tune pianos that
certificate how about that day its
achievement day as an example obviously
not everyone is certified to work on
Berzin work and orphans in the Steinway
Yamaha please okay I like that so what's
the third the third one is Father's Day
Father's Day Father's days
I never really celebrated with my dad
and now we've kept the rich tradition of
not start one bench one color I'm gonna
I'm gonna cut birthday okay because I
always forget them I'm going to bench
Valentine's Day and I'll start that
Father's Day why not self-serving
alright last one for you let's do the
movie one here okay best Paul Newman
movie no The Hustler Cool Hand Luke
Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid of
the man who owns more book Paul
and driven race cars than any other
human being on the planet well this is
difficult obviously I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna throw a curve here okay go for
now because the theme of the show I'm
going to cut Cool Hand Luke even though
it's great I'm going to bench the Butch
Cassidy and Sundance good and I'm gonna
start slap shot there you go because of
the sports theme and because that movie
is wildly underrated in the comedy
department that is a very funny sports
Adam Carolla you can come on the show
and tune my piano any time and that's
not a metaphor for anyhow well then I'm
at the Adam Carolla Show is out five
days a week go to Adam Corolla calm for
more information live podcast at the
Grove of Anaheim on Friday November
thirtieth with Rob Riggle you are the
man sir thank you my friend but you bet
my wife love being on your show time I
love to have it around the show I got to
come out to please I'll do the home at
home please do you really mean that if
they do I love I told your wife is she
she related and you want me to park my
car in front of your house for a few
days like this well no just give me the
decal I'll take it at to Adam Carolla on
Twitter we'll set up the rest of the
week in a moment the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience